because the American Dream is still
alive absolutely it's given me purpose
and it gives a lot of people purpose I
think it's harder for some together than
others yes I believe the American Dream
is still alive no the American Dream is
definitely not alive absolutely but it
depends on how you define it the white
picket fence gonna Trevor two kids
beautiful wife yes yes yes although I
think there are a lot of people who are
losing hope and being able to achieve it
the American Dream was never alive a
fantasy that we've clunked - that's cost
us the American Dream as traditionally
understood is dead but it's been
reinvented in millions and millions of
wonderful ways so I would say it's more
about making it more possible for more
people and that means that we have to
think about more people as America my
American Dream is that every family can
have the same opportunities as the most
privileged family in America and that we
can all make the best of this country to
be able to do what I want to do with my
life where I want to do it and
surrounded by the people that I love the
most
it's really to give back to my community
my parents and everyone who's around me
that's helped me throughout my life my
American dream is to influence the world
in a positive way acknowledging our role
in the world acknowledging that we are
of the world in which every person in
the United States that healthcare could
earn a living and support themselves and
have a home I love this idea of the
pursuit of happiness that to me is very
important and just to have access to the
same things about my fellow Americans
house so my American dream actually is
to become a citizen of the United States
I'm actually currently a docker
recipient my American dream is to make
my parents
my dream is who become a renowned artist
we'll see in a few years you may have a
deja vu when you see me on the big
screens and you'll say you know what I
was right that kid didn't make his dream
happen and we're out of all place in the
world and the best place which is here
in the United States of America